bill cosby sexual assault trial could be
one step closer to a mistrial the 79
year old left court last night after
another day of indecision the deadlock
jury is trying to determine whether
Cosby is guilty of drugging and
assaulting andrea constand in 2004
dozens of Cosby's accusers and
supporters gathered outside the
courthouse in Norristown Pennsylvania
and DeMarco Morgan is there tomorrow
good morning good morning the jury
appears to be tired they have been
living in a hotel hundreds of miles away
from home
pulling 12-hour days and eating every
bill in court last night we saw a pizza
boxes being brought into the courthouse
but after more than 40 hours of
deliberations they are unable to
unanimously agree on any of the 3
charges against him no matter how
endearing the character these people
play they are not above the law to
appeal Cosby's accusers addressed
reporters outside the courthouse
Thursday night earlier in the day Judge
Stephen O'Neal told jurors to keep
trying to reach a verdict former
prosecutor Dennis McAndrew says it's up
to Judge O'Neill to decide what happens
next the judge can declare a hung jury
and declare a mistrial which allows a
new trial for the defendant we
definitely want this thing to end
shortly before jurors for let go
Thursday night Cosby's publicist Andrew
why it called on judge O'Neil to step in
hopefully the judge would make a
decision and give us an update constant
attorney said the jury is apparently
working very hard and other high-profile
cases it has taken less time to reach a
verdict
not guilty of the crime of murder
deliberations of the OJ Simpson trial
took about four hours a may be seen it
and a Florida jury found Casey Anthony
not guilty of murder in less than 11
the jury in michael jackson's child
molestation trial spent about 30 hours
before finding him not guilty on
thursday constan a former temple
basketball director tweeted a video of
herself sinking a shot with a text
always follow through if this does end
in mistrial the prosecution has the
option of retrying cosby that's if
constan wants to go through another
trial gale all right we're all waiting
to hear thank you to mark